good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series the lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series is focused on the use of
data science methodology's artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
differing themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we listen to talks
from leading thinkers about the issues
promises opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covet 19.
these include delayed Health checkups
and treatments and mental health and
drug abuse increased obesity and the
long lingering health effects associated
with this terrible virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle is now open
and will be for only a few more days and
so time is running out we really
encourage you to if you're a junior
faculty member working in this space or
working in spaces such as infectious
diseases epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as data
science machine learning Ai and
statistics and other relevant domains to
please consider applying we have doing
this for a while now and we believe this
is a very exciting and engaging program
where characterizing the secondary
health effects this year characterizing
the secondary health effects of covid-19
really necessitates unique quantitative
approaches but also new
multi-disciplinary collaborations
the participants selected for our
biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage presentations like
we're about to hear as vital material
for our culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held
at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023. so
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr vinay pie from the U.S Food
and Drug Administration Dr pie is one of
our mentors this year for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab and he is a
digital health specialist within the
digital Health Center of Excellence at
the Food and Drug Administration Center
for devices in radiological Health in
the office of strategic Partnerships and
Technology Innovation part of the
division of Health at the FDA and he's
been there since uh September of 2019.
uh vinay has his PhD in mechanical
engineering from Florida State
University and earned a masters of
Business Administration from John Johns
Hopkins University currently he is
focused on Horizon scanning for new
digital Health Technologies evaluating
existing and emerging digital Health
Technologies and helping to develop
strategies for how to evaluate them
prior to his time at the Food and Drug
Administration Renee was at the National
Institutes of Health First as a staff
scientist in the National heart lung and
Blood Institute
and then as a program of officer and
division director for biomedical Imaging
informatics and health informatics at
the National Institute of biomedical
Imaging and bioengineering before the
NIH vinay was a faculty member at New
York University School of Medicine
developing techniques using proton and
hyperpolarized helium magnetic resonance
imaging to study cardiac and lung
function in continuing with our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series the nay's lecture today
is entitled so you want to Market your
regulated digital Health device in the
United States as fda's Center for
devices in radiological Health recently
established the digital Health Center of
Excellence to provide regulatory advice
guidance and support to the fda's
regulatory review of device software
functions a large number of early stage
digital Health Products struggled to get
to the U.S market due to the perception
of difficulty navigating the cdrh
regulatory processes vinay is going to
walk us through the various Pathways for
bringing digital Health devices and
Technologies to Market in the United
States he's also going to highlight the
guidance documents within the digital
health and medical device portfolios
which can help and be useful during the
process of moving digital Health
Technologies from prototype to real
world deployment as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have for Dr pie via the
chat feature in their Zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that
vinay welcome we are so excited to have
you here speaking to us today so excited
to have you as a mentor and we are
really looking forward to hearing your
lecture
thanks Jack uh hope you can hear me well
um and you can see my slide yep thank
you
um thanks again for the introduction and
I'm going to jump right into the
presentation because it's fairly
extensive
um and my presentation is going to focus
uh the way I'm planning on doing this by
showing some background content on the
agency and the technology that we're
working with before doing a deeper dive
into guidances that are applicable for
digital health
um when you talk about the U.S foreign
Drug Administration it's a it's a
regulatory agency and the key word that
is Regulatory and our responsibility is
protecting Public Health
um the agency does this through
regulating a wide range of products as
you can see here which range from like
human drugs and biological products
animal drugs medical devices tobacco
products food cosmetics and radiation
emitting electronic products and
obviously the entire the camera activity
is so vast that it's not run out of one
Center there are several centers within
the FDA which are responsible for
regulating these various aspects of the
agency and these are mentioned on the
left and the right of the screen and
yeah we also have extra additional
centers like the oncology center of
excellence so
when you look at cdrh which is one of
the centers as I mentioned it's Center
for devices and radiological health and
this is a Center focus on medical
devices and um
it goes without saying that patients are
at the heart of what we do and our
centers of vision as articulated by Dr
Jeff shurin and is that we want to
ensure that U.S patients have access to
high quality safe and effective medical
devices or public health importance and
first in the world so we shouldn't be
lagging and having these devices come to
the use of the US public in patients as
soon as possible
um I wanted to switch uh topics a little
bit going from looking at an agency
perspective to start looking at what do
you mean what do we mean by digital
Health technology because obviously uh
when you come from an academic setting
um you have a pretty broad spectrum of
things and so when we think about
digital Health Technologies we see how
we see these things as convergence of
computing power connectivity uh sensors
and software that are used in healthcare
and are applicable over the spectrum of
healthcare as you can see from
on the top where I can see from Healthy
Living all the way out to like managing
disease or treatment and having how
patients are utilizing these
Technologies in their treatment and Care
Um this can also be either be used as
medical products or be
used to study a medical product or be
either be incorporated into a medical
product like a combination product or
can be used as a companion or adjunct to
a medical product including Diagnostics
and Therapeutics so
taking a little bit further on this axis
it's like when you look at the solutions
that are coming out in digital health
and Landscape is pretty Broad and if you
look at it you're not only thinking
about moving the healthcare from the
clinic to the patient but you're also
trying to understand how behavior and
Physiology is being
impacted or looked at in the real world
versus looked at in control clinical
trials right and so digital Health gives
us a lot of power in understanding some
of these aspects which they had
difficulty doing before and if you look
at the type of solutions that you're
seeing come out into the marketplace
arranged quite a bit from like wearables
where you look at like sleep apnea
monitors or neurological models and like
Telecare which is like activity
monitoring which has been pretty useful
for like pandemic uh conditions as you
know and also thinking of things like
health and wellness Solutions where
people uh companies are coming out with
approaches for improving different
functions and trying to make sure that
these devices can help the US patient
population as much as possible and
the diversity also gives us an
interesting challenge because basically
while you're trying to achieve the
situation of U.S patients getting access
to
um medical devices Public Health
importance first in the world you also
want to make sure that they are high
quality and they are safe and effective
so balancing that
those two sort of competing interests is
always important to be careful that we
don't miss that Target in that sense
so as you notice the landscape is pretty
Broad and it's evolving very rapidly and
so in order to make sure that the agency
was on top of things here we launched in
2020 the digital Health Center of
Excellence or DH soe and this was
basically driven by our ongoing
commitment to advancing access to uh
digital Health technology
collaboratively
the goal our goal in the center is to
empowered stakeholders to Advance Health
Care by fostering responsible and high
quality digital Health Innovation and we
seek to find ways to tailor our
regulatory approaches
um that is fit for purpose for these
Imaging Technologies including like
artificial intelligence and machine
learning which has obviously a huge
potential to a personal impact Public
Health
in we believe that this is a shared goal
for all stakeholders involved in this
space and we are a partner and
contributor in the overall ecosystem and
we want for Australia responsible
Innovation to make sure that our
standards of safety and effect in us are
met
from our perspective the digital Health
Center of Excellence has three
components in this addressing this goal
um one is that you want to connect the
work that's being done both inside the
FDA and outside the FDA to other parts
of the ecosystem and secondly we want to
bring that knowledge together creating a
network that people can stand upon so
that there's less duplication and we can
drive Synergy and
the overall emphasis of all this is to
make sure that we can innovate and that
the Innovation not just like new
technology coming to the U.S population
but also make sure that this technology
is
safe and effective
these are some of the areas of focus as
you can see that it's a pretty broad
sort of areas and it's a sort of living
document incense that obviously new
technologies coming on online as every
day and so we had to be on top of these
things and some of these are also
cross-cutting to the Technologies
already out there like real world
evidence is a area of active interest
across the entire Center and the agency
and also this is not quite an exhaustive
list obviously but we are looking at a
lot of new and exciting areas of
authorization and looking at it from a
pre-marketer and post Market space like
for example virtual reality and
augmented reality and also looking at
AIML and ranging from Advanced
manufacturing approaches also to Patient
generated Health Data or pght as we talk
about
so while we before we go down further
into this very uh focused area of
interest from a digital Health
perspective I think it's important to
make sure that we are all on the same
page on some of the basic concepts that
how the agency looks at things
um versus how we may consider these
words or concepts outside the agency or
outside the scope of a pre-market
authorization space
so the first thing is we have to be
careful when you talk about a thing
called a device or a product so when the
agency talks about a device we are
basically saying that a definition that
comes to us from the federal drug and
cosmetic act section 201h and that's
listed here in detail and basically the
I'm not going to read the whole
definition and you can read it obviously
but there's some key aspects to this
definition right first of all at the top
you're having these kind of
um content about what this thing is
right like it could be an instrument
apparatus Implement and so on and so
forth but the other two aspects the key
aspects here are the two bullets here
the first one is like what is the
intended use of this particular thing
which is going to be considered as the
device well if it is used in diagnosing
a disease or curing mitigating treating
or preventing of disease then it's a
device right and so that's key when you
come with the product to the FDA what
are you doing with that product what is
the intended use of that product so that
is one of the key driving forces how we
look at a device how we look at a
product whether it's considered a device
for us or not and the second thing we
look at is like okay what is it doing
um like is it intended to affect the
structure or any function of the body
and we're also delineating a device from
a drug or a biologic where we say that
it does not achieve its primarily
intended purpose through chemical action
right so a device is not a drug so so
we're going to be careful about how we
Define these things and so it also helps
you understand which part of the agency
your particular product might end up in
based upon how you how the intended use
of your device or product is set up and
so you want to be careful when you're
thinking about your product when you're
building a product where you start from
an academic Circle to going out to
a startup or to a company and saying
okay this is what I want to do think
about this definition clearly and make
sure that what you're doing with what
are you intending to use this particular
thing that you're building where does it
fit in the spectrum of things that can
be regulated
um when you talk about devices uh as I
said before it's all dependent upon how
you what the intended use of the devices
and also how we describe or the device
is actually doing and what its
technological characteristics are and
then based upon those two criteria the
level of regulatory control from the
agency that is going to be given for
that particular product will be inside
it and we typically have three different
classes class one class two and class
three and the as you go up in risk of
the device you go to a higher class and
the other thing we have to mention here
is that
um basically like we use something
called Product codes or Pro codes which
is allowing us to
um group similar devices together and
make sure that we can sort of build a
family of devices where they are doing
the same intended use and so you can if
you look at a product code you can tell
what are the devices that have been
cleared under that product code
so
um I I believe that this is going to be
a lot of new Concepts coming to you
because I used to be the United and when
I moved to NIH to FDA the language
changes of how we speak about scientific
things if I may say that so here just it
may be a little bit confusing as a lot
of new definitions come here just be
patient and you can go back and listen
to the talk and get more feeling
understanding of what actually these
concepts mean
so
um this slide reiterates some of the
points I mentioned in the previous slide
and the key thing to note here as I said
like classes one two and three and the
risk level is increasing at the higher
class but the main thing here is what
are the controls right we have something
called regulatory controls that are
applicable to a product area and these
are allowing us to provide consistent
requirements so make sure that
we are predictable safe and effective
medical devices and we have appropriate
level of regulatory oversight on these
devices and so these controls are
generally broad but maybe specific and
at the bottom I've listed the general
controls which are applicable even to
the lowest class devices which is
basically like you have to provide
labeling for your device then you have
to you have to do medical device
reporting for example if there are
device related injuries or that's you
have to report that to the agency then
you have to register your establishment
with the agency and then
here they have a device listing and like
you could have like a global device IDs
so approach and then your Quality
Systems that you would have in place
make sure that the device is safe and
effective and finally obviously you have
to make sure that you can track more
adulteration and misplanting Concepts
and these are the type of uh submission
types that we get to see
um Within These different classes and
this basically for a moderate risk it
typically will CFI 10K more than any
other type of submission you will see
some denova submissions too but most of
the time it'll be a 510k or exempt
submission then when you go to the
highest risk device you'll pretty much
end up with something called a
pre-market approval or PMA device which
is how which will have the highest
amount of regulatory control on those
devices
when you look at the class 2 devices
besides the general control we also have
something called special controls and
basically what we see here on the left
is these are very they're specific only
to class two devices not for class 1
devices and they're not typically common
but basically applicable for
well-established device types and when
you're looking for uh
example of where is a special control
applied then you can look at the when
you look at the code Federal Regulation
and you look at the B section of that
particular product it'll tell you like
okay what is the classification what are
the special controls that are applicable
to this particular device and if you
look at the I given some examples this
is not an exhaustive list but these are
some of the examples special controls
that are placed on these devices because
they are a little bit higher risk than
like a class one device but they're
obviously not as high as as a class 3
device
so you can have requirements when it's
coming in with your pre-market
submission like you need to provide
design or characteristics or
specifications then you need to provide
testing you may need special labeling
and there are some guidance documents
here to go through to make sure that
your device
um satisfies the special controls or be
before it can be allowed to be
authorized to be going out into Market
in the US
so here um this is a very simplistic and
brief outline of the steps for bringing
a new product to Market in the US uh
through the FDA and I think the most
important part in this particular slide
is the link at the bottom because
um I think cdrh learn would be a very
valuable asset for if if you're bringing
a device to Market in the US because it
walks you through uh in fairly simple
approach and logic that how you can
explain all the process aspects for
bringing your device to the market in
the US and what are the various aspects
of how we do research How We Do how you
get your data together how you make sure
that your Quality Control process is in
place how you make sure you verify and
validate your devices operation and so
some of those things will be more easily
explained in that site
um and and this is this slide doesn't do
justice too the expansive aspect of this
thing and
but very briefly going over the slide
babe what do you start out this is
pretty much sequentially what you want
to do is lucky first of all you want to
establish your product make sure that
it's description and the intended to use
the indications were used the duration
of views like how long should we use in
the Target population like for example
uh it could be age range which you
wanted water age range is it applicable
for what type of populations what
disease is it applicable for those kind
of things you want to get that clear
first and then you want to go to like
you want to verify that this product is
actually medical device remember as I
said the federal drug Food Drug and
cosmetic act tells us like what is the
device and so does your once you define
your intended use does it fit within
that particular definition or not where
does it fit in that scope and then once
you've done that like
you want to find the classification
regulatory pathway is it going to be
class 1 Class 2 class 3 and which
particular pathway do you want to go
down based upon the risk it'll tell you
once you have figured out that these are
the things I have to do then you then go
ahead and build your evidence for your
scientific evidence make sure that you
can come in with the free market
submission but I would strongly
encourage any or any of you who's
interested in bringing a device to
Market is work with the FDA as early as
possible because the earlier you get
those involved in your process
development of even from like once you
established that this is what you want
to do you can come in and talk to us and
say okay this is my intended use where
do I fit in your scope of controls and
it might be something as simple as
saying okay your device we don't or
you're a product we don't regulate in
which case you might have a different
pathway versus we say Okay a high risk
products because you're doing X Y and Z
and so having that conversation right at
the bat I think it's going to be very
valuable rather than waiting till you
are up at step five and then coming and
talking to us and then realizing you had
to go back and redo a lot of things
because you totally misunderpreted what
regulatory systems are so talk to our
review divisions as much as possible and
you can all I'll put out I'll provide an
email address reach out to us
and we can connect you with the review
divisions which are appropriate for your
particular product but please do work
with us as early as possible rather than
waiting till the end
um
but when you talk about devices then
question becomes how does that apply in
the scope of digital health and it gets
very interesting when you talk about
devices in the digital Health Spectrum
so we start out on this initial
definition right which is saying the
section 201h of the food drug and
cosmetic act has a definition for device
an Indian product that's not within that
spectrum is going to be something that
we considered not a device so okay
that's clean and easy but then the
Nuance that quicksand kicks in is that
we have the 21st stage cures act that
came in and said that okay when you're
thinking about software functions there
are some parts of software functions
that should not be considered as a
device that should be regulated by the
FDA and so once you start thinking about
that aspect then you realize that there
are a lot of software Solutions the
software functions that you can develop
which don't necessarily have to come to
the FDA and you can go straight to
Market
and so this is uh the first guidance I
think which uh which is the power listed
at the bottom here which we call the
3060 guidance and basically what it is
doing is it's listing the changes that
apply to existing medical software
policies because of this cures act and
as you can see here from left to right
like there are a lot of software
functions that it talks about which it
says that these are sort of functions
that do not need to be
regulated by the FDA and so I'll be
going to more detail into these
different sort of functions um as you go
forward but think about when you're
building your product like where does it
fit in this spectrum does it fit in
these kind of
um sort of buckets or not and then
that's where you go from like how when
you talk to the FDA also
and
in the previous slide I mentioned the
word function and I want to make sure
that when we talk about function within
the agency or within like pre-market
space or in the authorization space we
have a different meaning than like a
mathematical function right so in here
we are talking about a distinct purpose
of a product and so when we talk about
a function a device function basically
it's a function that meets the
definition of a device so that's
something that we can potentially
regulate and then when you say device
software function we talk about a
software function that meets the device
definition so you want to be careful
that when you say function here we talk
about how does this thing function what
does it do and
basically when we and as it goes back to
the pointer is the beginning of this
talk which is like the whole thing
hinges on intended use of the product
what is the product doing so the
intended use is a function of that
particular product and you can have
multiple intended users and so for
example if you just are having one
intended use which is analyzing the data
then it's only one function which is
analyzed data on the other end if it's
Integrity you store transfer and analyze
then it has three different functions
right it has a function to store it has
function to transform it is a function
that will analyze the data that's come
through it and do something with that
right so you want to be careful that
when you start to build your product you
have to think about what are the
functions of this product and what which
basically translates to what are the
intended uses of this product and then
you can go down to Pathways okay this is
a device function or it's not a device
function
and so when you talk about not a device
function sort of thing we talk about
other functions and I'll come back to
this later but basically it's a function
that does not mean the definition of a
device so it can be an intended use but
it might be an intent to use that
doesn't fit under Section 201 edge of
the food drug and cosmetic acts and so
or it could be something like it could
be an exempt kind of function so you
want to be careful about the nuances
that apply to any of the functions of a
device and so when we're looking at
which functions are being reviewed by
the FDA then it's it'll be called device
function review and so on and so forth
so obviously I'm not suggesting that you
memorize all this and you shouldn't but
it's a slide that I put up we can go
back and look at it and these are
definitions that are available on the
FDA website and you can look at them and
understand the nuances of how things are
looked at when they come into the agency
the other thing I was also going to
mention is when you think about the
intended years which I mean uh sort of
mentioning all along is like
um we had an amendment um to this in
intended use through the 24-hour CFR
code of federal court Federal Regulation
801 where basically like there was some
aspect related to okay how do you define
intended use right how do you know what
the products intended to use is and so
here we provided more clarity and
Direction regarding what type of
evidence can be used to determine its
intended use and so we can use any
relevant source of evidence which can
include direct evidence you might have
supplied or
um to us when you submitted your
application or like interact with
circumstantial evidence such as how
you're selling the product in the
marketplace and quotes that recognized
that self-serving labels cannot be used
or cannot be allowed to mask the vendors
true intent as indicated by the overall
circumstances so
the intended use can be determined using
these different
um
approaches to truly understanding
whether person or the spawn the device
manufacturer or product manufacturers
how is how are they trying to sell this
device so what is it being sold for
so going back to the regulatory
classification question when you talk
about digital Health Products
um where does a particular digital
Health product sit is dependent upon the
risk categorization of that device and
the intended use of the device so you
can either be a not a device we are
looking at remember a device is not a
product device is something the ftnc act
or we can intend to use exercise
something called enforcement discretion
and I'll come to that in the future next
subsequent slide or it'll be under the
regulatory oversight of the Ft in which
case it's a different pathway it goes
down
so when you look at software functions
right and
um
basically like if it's a software
function
the we want to look at how it's
regulated and you can see at the bottom
there's an error which goes increasing
risk and basically as I said in the
previous slide as a risk of a device
increases the risk of the intendities of
the device increases then the more
oversight comes into play from the fda's
perspective and so if you're on the left
hand side of the risk cab flow then you
are basically looking at functions that
are intended for like a log record so
this is an example right so in which
case we're saying that you can either
log record track a wallet or make
decisions or behavioral suggestions but
there's no reference to a disease or a
condition in this in this particular
example on the other hand we start
adding more information like we're
trying to help smokers quit or
you want to help patients recovering
from addiction or you're developing apps
or pregnant women then these are apps or
you may the risk level is higher and
then the agency has an intent to
exercise enforcement discretion
depending on the where the risk sits on
that particular profile for those
particular devices
and finally then if you're looking at a
product where you're building a sort of
function that uses sensors or leads to
track measure and display like
electrical signal like ECG then those
are higher risk products and so we
definitely have a regulatory oversight
on those products
foreign
so in order to help industry and
consumers get clarity on the regulatory
aspects related to software
um cdrh has been has released a number
of guidance documents over the last few
years as I've shown here uh some of
these are in draft state which means
that there's not considered final
guidances and they are currently they're
accepting public comment or we are
evaluating uh comments that have been
provided by the public before after the
commenting period is closed and the
final guidance will be published
sometime soon
um but definitely these are documents
that are can be sometimes difficult to
read and understand but can be once I
mean they're very valuable in helping
you understand how the agency is
interpreting uh authorizations or
Congressional authorizations rewarded to
it
I think the key uh tool that you may
want to start out with is something
called the digital Health policy
Navigator this is something that the
digital Health Center of Excellence
recently made available it's on our
fta's website and this is mainly to help
product developers understand how their
software function fits within the
regulatory framework of the agency it's
an interactive workflow and you
basically uh answer different questions
which are shown here like different
steps and based upon how we answer these
questions it's a rule-based system where
it basically takes you down different
Pathways and it tells you like okay
based upon how we answered a particular
set of questions
um you will either be like will not be a
medical device or it could be some a
device or a product where enforcement
discretion applies or a device where you
have to come in and talk to us and have
regulatory oversight on that and so and
it's a nice starting point it's
um but it's not the be all an end also
just because it tells you one thing it
doesn't necessarily mean you shouldn't
and talk to us but I think it's a good
starting point to tell you where you are
in that spectrum of which guidance is
applied to your particular device
so I want to do a deeper dive into some
of the aspects related to software
functions that we talked about and so
um I'm going to start with more of the
functions that we don't have the FDA
doesn't have kind of
considered as devices and so this is
coming from the section 5201a of the
fdnc act and basically any software
function that you build which is for
administrative administrative support of
a healthcare facility those types of
functions are historically not
considered to be devices by the agency
and so I've provided some examples here
where basically if you are
uh tracking Financial records claims of
billing information or you're looking at
building scheduling for your medical
staff or if you're building a software
for like analyzing historical claims
data for cost effect in us or looking at
health benefit eligibility those are the
functions that the FDA doesn't get in
um look at as devices it's not to say
that any other regulatory agency within
the federal government may or may not
have it uh opinion on how these
functions are deployed but from the FDA
perspective this is not something we
look at
um then the second one I think it's a
interesting one for digital health
because they will see a lot of products
out there that make a large number of
General awake claims about health so uh
when we talk about General Wellness we
we are basically considering two
different types of products so one is
that either the intended for only
General Wellness use as defined in the
guidance of General Wellness
or and they present at lower risk to the
safety of these in other persons and
basically what we're saying here is that
we do not intend to examine low risk
General Wellness products and basically
the thing becomes like how how are you
defining these kind of risk low risk and
General Wellness and so one of the ways
if you look at the guidance the two
categories that we talk about winter
about low risk and uh but if you make if
your product is making claims about
sustaining or offering General
Improvement
uh to functions associated with the
general cdfl then do not make any
reference to disease or condition then
that's one category of General Wellness
on the other hand if you're talking
about making reference to disease or
condition you're only
um making intelligence claims of
sustaining or offering General
Improvement functions associated with
the general state of health and so
basically we are talking about
relationship between healthy lifestyle
choices and sustaining a general state
of health so
think about these aspects when you are
trying to think whether you're in the
devices your products intended to use is
a general awareness or not and so when
you are in that space I would recommend
again as I said before come and talk to
us
the next one I want to talk about is
electronic health records and this is an
interesting area of focus basically that
um under the section 5201 C of the fdmc
ACT some software functions that are
intended to serve as electronic patient
records are not considered as devices
and so these are three different
conditions that apply they have to all
we have to be met and the first two I
think the third one is the most
interesting one and basically the first
one basically says we're creating it for
people like for healthcare professionals
or individuals working under Healthcare
professionals supervision are the ones
looking at creating and storing or
reviewing these kind of Records they
also have to be part of like no NC
Office of the national coordinator for
Health Information Technology based upon
the Public Health Service Act 3001 CF
and so if it's under that program and
the third thing which is important is to
know that these should not be intended
for interpretation analysis
no patient records including like
medical image data but the purpose of
diagnosis cure mitigation prevention on
treating of disease or condition and if
you
if you remember this the last part of
the language actually comes if from the
food food drug and cosmetic act right
we'll talk about the intendities of this
particular function and where does it
fit in so if you're using that
particular function for these kind of
activities then yes that would be a
device because of the it's doing
diagnosis cure and all that other
potential possibilities
the other thing to mention about the EHR
is that basically at this time there's
some overlap with um I think I mentioned
the second criteria that there's overlap
the onc uh which is part of the
statutory definition of this particular
uh process and so even after you
established that a product is an EHR you
have to be careful the fact is that when
you're talking about product functions
that just because you have an EHR
function does not mean that other
functions of your device are not or
every product are not a device right so
you want to be careful about you might
have one function which is the HR but
there might be another function which
might be doing something which is
which can be considered as the device
for the FDA so you want to consider all
these functions separately and also a
value you want to evaluate that anything
either you add new functionality to your
product see how that impacts within that
fdnc act
and again going back to the 3060 act
3060 guidance you want to look at how
the different criteria are describing
electronic health records for healthcare
professionals and we also said that in
the second bullet we're talking about
like how if it enables patients
individuals to non-healthcare Providers
to create store or transfer health
records They are considered personal
health records so these are not meant
for as I said before because they're not
meant for intended use of diagnosis key
or mitigation so on so forth they would
also not be considered devices under the
ftnc ACT section 201h
um going on to the next guidance um this
one is uh interesting one because it's
talking about medical device it's a
pretty long name for the guidance which
is basically talking about medical
device Data Systems medical image
storage devices and medical image
Communications devices and we I have a
short economy for that it's called mdds
and basically these are hardware and
software Hardware or software products
that are mainly intended to transfer
store convert formats and display
medical device data the key here is that
the mtds cannot or does not modify the
data or modify the display of the data
and does not control the functional
parameters so like for example if you
think about a hardware device a router
would be considered Hardware device it
just transfers data from one point to
point point A to point B and it doesn't
modify the data or modify the display of
the data and does not control the
functional parameters of any other
medical device so it depends on how you
look at it and it's very valuable to
think about your device whether it's an
mdds or non-mtds and so
when you think about
um mtds system we have software
functions and we have Hardware functions
and so each of these can be considered
differently and if it's it's a software
function that just transfers towards a
converts format and doesn't uh do all
the modifications that are controlled
then it's not a device and it won't be
subject to regulate requirements
similarly when you think about Hardware
functions that again do the same kind of
activity or actions then those are
considered as
device mdds and for certain device
entities we do not intend to enforce the
requirements
the next interesting part as you
transition from like General Wellness
from tmtds to clinical decision support
systems
um this is a interesting area because
there's a lot of action we're seeing
from artificial intelligence so machine
learning related to clinical dishes and
support systems and so CDs is basically
a tool that allows Healthcare
professionals and patients to get more
information and to filter that and have
it presented to them at appropriate time
to ensure that health and Healthcare is
delivered correctly
um so the key is obviously you want to
make sure that these are all safe and
effective and there are a lot of
different aspects of CDs as you can see
here like you can range from like
clinical guidances guidelines to
developing diagnostic support or having
contextually relevant reference
information so uh
this field is pretty big and Broad and
we have
um
um the cures act has talked about like
the 5201e that the fdnc ACT has also
provided some information like as to how
do we decide whether
the particular CDs is uh something that
should be considered as a device or can
be excluded from the device function and
so there are four statutory criteria
that have been defined in this
particular section of the ACT which are
allowing us to determine whether
particular function becomes a device or
not device and so when we talk about
non-device we're talking about basically
those functions that do not mean the
definition of device right that we
talked about before and the other thing
is like when you talk about functions
which are excluded from device
definition we have to be clear that
these are independent of the platform
that they're being run on so it could be
running on as Android or iOS it doesn't
matter it does you know these functions
are excluded from device definition
independent of that
so these are the four criteria from the
cures act right and so the key here is
that all four conditions have to be met
or um there so if you look at it uh
there it starts you start from the first
one you go down the rank that way and
basically the first two are basic input
kind of uh aspects basically you're
saying that is it intended to acquire
process analysts a medical image or the
second one is intended for displaying
something and then the last term I mean
look came from the output perspect like
is it providing an intended to provide
recommendation and for finally is it
like intended for enabling uh Healthcare
professional independently review the
basis of such recommendations so any CDs
software that you develop it has to meet
all four conditions to be excluded from
the device definition so it can be a
little hard to make sure that you hit
all four of them
um this cartoon like sketch or graphic
outline which is available online fda's
website
um it's sort of like a cheat sheet of
how this process works and so the top
row is basically saying that if it meets
all these four criteria that are shown
here then that particular one would be
considered as a non-device CDS but if it
fails any of them then you are no longer
you are pretty much a device and we will
be regulating you and so for example if
you look at uh a device example if
you're looking at in vitro Diagnostics
or you can MRI and next-gen sequencing
those kind of functions are
you're failing this particular step one
right and then you go to like step two
for already looking at like ECG you are
looking at Medical images and then this
question becomes okay how are you
looking at those confirmation and then
the other examples here looking at like
Risk score for disease or conditions and
probability of a disease or a condition
that you might have and then final time
critical outputs are something that we
always are concerned about and finally
like here we look at if you if your AI
for example if a algorithm is not
providing the basis of the
recommendation that it provides you as
to why a vertical action is Justified to
be taken and if if the clinician cannot
understand why that's being done then
that's something that people want to see
as a device
um going further down we're talking
about
um
policy for device software functions the
Mobile Medical applications or as you
call it the tsf MMA guidance and this is
an interesting guidance because it's a
it's a fairly broad guidance and it's
very useful reading to understand what
kind of aspects of
digital Health come under the different
Umbrellas of whether it's a device or it
comes under reinforcement discretion or
whether it's regulated by the FDA and so
I think it's a very useful starting
point when you start to look at digital
Health Products like which guidance you
want to start with I think I would
recommend this particular guidance it's
all our guidance is obviously well
written but this I think feels like a
very nicely collected Gardens and it's
sort of like a first go-to guidance when
we have any example or a question come
into us about a digital Health inquiry
and then we say okay how did we
interpret it in this particular guide
and so I think
um if you're starting out in the field
it's a good guide to start out with and
some of the other aspects related to
this particular guidance is beside the
fact that it defines some of these
functions it also talks about like we do
not regulate the sale or you generally
use of consumer use or smartphones or
tablets and so this was one of the
things I think comes easy out output
from this guidance
but I think as I mentioned before the
main things that are relevant here is
the fact that we're talking about where
are the regulatory oversights that have
been established through this guidance
we're talking about
um it walk um basically we're talking
about which software functions are
medical devices are not medical devices
and which are the ones where we intend
to exercise enforcement discretion and
the right hand side talks about what do
we mean by enforcement discretion right
basically we're saying that even if it
meets the definition of medical device
we do not intend to exercise enforcement
like basically like uh we believe that
these functions are for proposing lower
risk to the public based upon the
evidence we have in the field or from
scientific literature and so
um
generally we intend to exercise
enforcement discussion for several
different types of examples and
um if it's something that's helping a
patient self-manage the disease or
condition without providing specific
treatment or treatment suggestions then
we definitely are looking in that space
and so I'll list two here but this is
not exhaustive and if you if you you can
go back to that guidance and look at the
different examples and different
scenarios that have been laid out of how
enforcement policies uh implemented in
those conditions I think um that would
be a good guidance look through
the last one I want to talk about is
something called the multiple function
guidance and this is a when you think
about a product which has multiple
functions um remember we talk about let
me say functions we talk about internet
use and so
um depending on different intended use
this guidance gives you clarity about
how we look at the other functions right
and so you look at the right hand side
we talk about what's another function
well it doesn't meet the definition of a
device or if it meets it then there's
some kind of exemption that's applicable
or if it's meeting the difference but
some kind of intent the FDA is
expression is not to enforce compliance
and so when you talk about these kind of
other functions as being part of a
device itself then how does the FDA look
at those particular functions and this
particular guy this
multiple function guidance walks you
through some of those aspects so just
because they're part of a multiple
function device doesn't mean we want to
look at it on the other hand we will
look at how this particular other
function impacts the the device function
that we're actually interested in right
so you want to make sure that the device
function that you're reviewing
are not in their safety and infection is
not impacted by these other function
that you have sitting on the side so for
example if you have a general purpose
Computing platform we don't regulate
that but we are interested to know how
does that General function general
purpose Computing platform that you're
using for your app which is sitting on
top of that how does that interaction
work and how are you ensuring that your
app is safe and effective when there are
issues or aspects related to the general
purpose Computing platform so we would
ask for that kind of connection to be
established and so similarly for the
hardware that if you are looking at uh
integrastic balloon which is subject to
a PMA or pre-market approval and you
have an endoscope accessory that is 510k
exempt for example in a desktop guide
where we may still want to see how this
guide were impact the safety infection
of the balloon so in that sense you have
to be careful that when you look at
devices multiple functions how do the
other functions interact with your
function that you're actually coming to
the agency with for authorization
so
um basically if you look through the
gardens it'll talk you through like you
want to look at do a risk assessment
right and so when you do a risk
assessment you want to see what the
other function impacts as far as the
device function that review if there's a
positive impact like it improves safety
and Effectiveness right for example uh
increase gpus or
higher neural net or something like that
then you want it obviously improves
processing speed but it has something
that we want to look at and also you
want to see if there's an adverse effect
right if it's for example you added some
kind of lower capacity Ram or something
like that in which case obviously a
computation time slows down and so we
would like to know what kind of or if
you added a software Library which has
slower computation now it was not
updated for a while then in which case
those functions can impact adversely so
you want to know how does that
particular function even though it's not
necessarily something we would have
looked at but question becomes how does
it impact the safety and effectiveness
of the device function that we are
looking at and then so once you've
considered all those aspects of risk
assessment then you need to include that
in a pre-market submission that tells us
how these other functions impact
um this the device function that review
and you you mainly do that when you
either positively impacting and you're
going to show that uh for the function
the review and or if it's negatively
impacting the device function in the
review
so I know this is in a whirlwind tour of
digital Health at cdrs and
um Jack has my slide and this
information and as I said cdrs learn is
a great site to go to to learn more
about how we look at different devices
and how we regulate them I want to
conclude by just summarizing some of the
aspects I had on during this talk which
is basically saying like when you talk
about software function it's a device if
it's intended for use in the diagnosis
cure mitigation treatment or prevention
of a disease or condition and so what we
the way we the vocabulary we use if we
call them device software functions so
remember the word device has its own
meaning and then we take what software
functions that are meeting this device
definition so that's how we Define
software functions and then when you
look at the 21st century cures act
um there's some software functions that
are excluded from definition of a device
so and we have as I walked you through
several of our guidances these can help
you understand okay whether your
particular product is coming under that
or not right and so they'll help you
understand like whether you
um you need to walk through all the
different aspects or not but I think at
this end of the day having good quality
control systems in your processes as you
build your product is going to be always
valuable even if it's a device not
authorized not coming under FDA uh or
purview I think for success of your
product and your company I think it's
valuable for you to build good quality
control systems within your product
development processes so that's
something I would encourage and then
when you look at regulatory oversight
we're looking at primarily sort of
functions that are medical devices and
we're looking at risk categorization if
it's functionality failure would impact
the safety of the patient then it's
something we're really interested and
want to oversee uh like from a
regulatory perspective and as I
mentioned uh towards the last few slides
that we recognize that there are
function products that have more than
one function or more than one intended
use and so the question becomes like you
want to make sure that when your other
functions how about those other
functions impacting the function that
you're looking at from a regulatory
perspective and you want to make sure
that we look at both positive and
negative aspects of those other
functions and the last thing I want to
point out is like there are several ways
you can reach out to us we have the
digital Health inbox which is as shown
here digital Health at fda.sha should go
where a number of guidance documents
that you have released and we also have
regulatory tools such as the digital
helpers Navigator and also cdrs learn is
another valuable tool which you can use
to get to understand how you bring your
product to Market in the U.S
so this is the last slide and basically
if you have any questions you can either
reach out to digital Health at
fda.hs.gov or you can email me also
directly if you need to
thank you vinay thank you so much this
um stuff you talked about here I think
will be of a lot of interest to many
folks who are parts of our biomedical
data sense Innovation lab and generally
speaking a lot of at least the work that
we're familiar with through our
interactions with the community from
where we sit here at UVA have been in
the space of developing computational
algorithms that are linked to some sort
of biometric device and so what you're
talking about here where there's the
device itself and there's the software
there's the interaction between the two
I think this is exactly the kind of
information that people who have these
if they're looking at cardiac function
or they've got their uh you know
basically looking at the eye for example
or they're you know making some other
metric like with a wearable device that
and they want to Market it that this is
the kind of information they need
definitely and I think
um the one thing I mentioned at the
beginning and I will keep happening
awaited because we have discussions with
within the agency also like
um any developer of a software should
come and talk to us as early as possible
and uh we are friendly we we are nice to
talk to us so uh please do reach out
early don't wait till the last minute
and then you I mean it's a lot of
investment as I mean when you build
startups it's a lot of upfront
Investments you want to make sure that
at a minimum you're on the right path
for this particular product I think
that's very very good advice one of the
things that um I wanted to ask about is
and we were sort of talking a little bit
about this before we got started today
but you brought it up several times and
you really kind of iterated on it um
about how much terms matter
um and the definitions of these words
that perhaps those of us who don't know
any better would use interchangeably but
you point out
um rightly so that you know that there
is a difference between in a device and
a product and you gave several other uh
several resources to uh for people to
look at to avoid confusion are there any
common mistakes that people make in
mixing up terms that could you know they
might use in one context but to the FDA
mean something else
um how to come back and look at because
I'm pretty sure there are now I've been
so immersed in the FDA approach of
thinking about things like sometimes
it's hard like I think I mentioned
before the call like the word signal has
a different meaning within FTA
connotations and
um I think also like words like
monitoring or I mean so post Market is
an interesting space where we look at
how devices perform in the real world
and so some of those aspects related to
how devices are monitored or tracked can
be meaning different things of different
agencies and so I think that's one
aspect I think device and product is the
most obvious one I think because we have
a clear I mean we
food Dragon cosmetic is act is clearly
defined for us what that means and those
words have specific meanings and I think
the other place where we are had aspects
that is in AIML because especially when
you talk about bias trying to understand
different types of bias like statistical
bias versus systemic bias and
understanding explainability of a
algorithm those are some of the nuances
that are different from different uh
perspective not just within the agencies
but also even in the academic Community
as to understanding what those
particular words mean
and I think one thing I was going to
mention is that we have something called
the imtrf which is international medical
device Regulators forum and we have
started to build glossary of words and
so that we also understand when we're
saying a particular verb that we're
talking about the same thing and
sometimes it can get lost that we may be
talking about the same word but me
talking about totally different concepts
and then takes a while to get back to
the same space yeah I think that's
probably super important just to have a
thesaurus of you know what those terms
are
um one of the things that occurred to me
as you were mentioning about evidence
and that word and what that means is is
the evidence that one needs to provide
in their application is it in narrative
form only or is like is there an
expectation of a live demonstration in
front of an FDA representative that your
device does what it says it does
so
um it's mostly been the farmer but we
also had situations where it has helped
us understand more about what a device
does by having a demonstration obviously
I mean it's not a requirement so it's up
to the so when we so when we use the
word sponsor a company coming in to
submit to us is called a sponsor right
they're sponsoring the product to come
in for review and so when a sponsor
comes in uh and they show us a video or
they show us their uh product it makes
it a lot easier to connect the dots
between what you're seeing on paper
versus what you're actually seeing in uh
demonstration and so we have several
examples of when we look at a submission
and say are you doing X Y and Z and then
we have a conversation with the sponsor
and they show us a demonstration of what
the product does and we realize how it
does X but it doesn't do y and its
intended uses not this but it's the
other thing and so
it's it's been always helpful to us to
have a demonstration or a video and
obviously uh with the pandemic and all
it's been hard to have a Hands-On demo
but you can do video presentation about
your product but part of the thing is
also we don't want to put on new
um burden on the sponsors saying that if
somebody cannot do a video it doesn't
mean they should be impaired from having
their device looked at like the right
circumstances so it's not a requirement
and but it definitely helps to
understand where you're coming from as a
device manufacturer that's great and a
lot of people I imagine in in this day
and age we've sort of gotten used to it
is with wearable devices and things that
you can wear on your wrist or on your
head or on your finger for that matter
are internet enabled and they have you
know Bluetooth technology attached to
them that connect to your cell phone or
they connect to the internet in some
shape or form and I'm curious if the FDA
works with other agencies for where
necessary for example like the Fed
Federal Communications Commission when
you're dealing with things that involve
say you know Wireless or wired
communication Technologies does that
make sense yeah yeah so we do work at a
FCC and FTC and obviously we do work
with onc and the CMS so we we do all
work with different agencies but if it's
just one particular product that we're
looking at the review of that product is
typically done in-house only we don't
necessarily go outside we um also have
something called a network of experts
for even for digital Health we call it
nodex which is network of digital Health
experts and so we use these network of
experts to help and understand if you
have questions about some scientific
aspect of things that so we reach out to
them and have these broad not product
specific but like fairly broad questions
about like okay in this particular field
these are if these are the kind of
questions we have how would we answer
that and so that's one way we do it and
we do work with the FCC and FTC like
Federal Trade community and to
understand like what are the kind of
broad ranging aspects or different
technologies that we have to think about
especially like within the low energy
Bluetooth and trying to understand the
like security implications so we have a
separate division within
um cdrs looking at cyber security aspect
of different devices and which is a very
strongly I mean it's a very uh
top a strong topic of interest for the
agency because of the various aspects of
how safety and effectiveness of devices
can be impaired by hacks and Legacy
devices being sort of unprotected so we
had a lot of interest in that space and
yeah we do talk to other agencies on
that front you sort of predicted my next
question which was uh what are one of
the things that or any of the things
because I think you touched on it but
you you didn't really go into the
details because you were talking about
other things but about subject and
patient privacy certainly with you know
you're developing a device perhaps it's
you know linked to you in some way and
yet it's you know sending information
over the internet are there any things
that you look at specifically to help
make sure that uh data that's
transmitted is private store you know
the Phi is removed I don't know what
some of the other things might be but uh
I'm curious about how you address those
so I think it depends uh so for almost
all our product questions the answer is
always it depends right and so if the
company needs that PS information to
make diagnosis like if it's a class 3
product or a product where there's a
patient specific recommendation being
made then obviously they want to have
that connectivity to the patient so from
that perspective the company has to be
responsible and has to show in the
documentation to submit to us how are
they protecting the patient information
how are they making sure that
um that confidentially is ensured we as
an agency don't see that information
because that's obviously not part of the
submission that comes to us but it's
basically like make sure that the
company knows how that has to protect
the information let us be enforcing
these aspects related to how the
patients feel about using the devices
and when you talk about safety and
Effectiveness you also think about like
human factors right like when we talk
about AR VR devices you want to
understand like how are the human
factors looked at when you're looking at
these devices and again they are the
confidential of information about like
surgeons you want to understand make
sure that you're looking at data
um inappropriate way and making sure the
data is uh protected so definitely yeah
that's something we do
um strongly uh work with the vendors
make sure that they have it under
control from that angle
um
that's great well benade we've reached
the end of our time but thank you so
much for sharing this with us this is
really valuable information and I think
it's important because it comes from
some place that you know we don't
complete in our history here in the uh
biomedical data science Innovation lab
activities we haven't really heard from
the FDA before and so uh thank you for
sharing this with us because I know for
a fact there's a lots of uh people who
are interested in this space and
productize it rather not productizing
but they're basically taking their
devices and their and their other uh
research products and marketing them and
having the help of you and Folks at the
FDA would really be valuable for them
cool
thank you very very much everyone have a
great weekend and uh we'll see you next
week bye now thanks